foreign
I get a lot of questions emails calls
all of it about seasonal affective
disorder or sad as the nerds say
uh actually the nerds say seasonal
affective disorder the cool kids say sad
so
um
here's what it is all right so if you
back up and and look take a 30 000 foot
View
um it's
the feeling you get it's this Lo it's
this feeling of being low of being
depressed of being underwater if you
will in the fall and into the winter and
all usually through the winter
um sometimes into the spring
um this is uh it has genetics in origin
it has family of origin and origin right
wherever your lineage comes from it all
that in all honesty
um if you want to go listen to Dr Andrew
huberman's podcast about it it can you
can go to a rabbit hole he's way smarter
than me on this stuff
um here's what I want you guys to know
number one it's a For Real shift it is
real okay and it's a down regulation as
the nerds say in mood and it affects
true seasonal affective disorder right
the actual depression affects about five
percent of the population give or take
but I think infinitely more folks
suffer from feel acutely that
down regulation of mood right and
here when I moved to Tennessee so I was
in West Texas which is about 30 or 45
minutes from one time zone
and I stayed in the same time zone
moving to Tennessee but now I'm in
Nashville and I'm 45 minutes from the
other time zone
and so at five o'clock in in late fall
and into the winter here in Nashville 4
30. it is Pitch Black outside
it is night night night dark
and my first year I moved here I
remember about February feeling like
something was sitting on my chest I
couldn't I couldn't breathe a lot I
thought something was wrong with me I
started thinking I'd taken the wrong job
I thought I just thought I wasn't okay
and then it occurred to me one day I was
walking to work and I was in by the way
I was going to work and it was Pitch
Black I was getting out of work and was
Pitch Black and there was just this gray
that hung over over the city of
Nashville for a couple of months
um it occurred to me oh
growing up in Texas in the South this is
the longest my body has ever gone
without sunlight
I'm gonna have to be really intentional
about
my mood and the things that affect my
mood right so I don't want us to get
caught up in the Diagnostic in the do I
have officially have seasonal affective
disorder or seasonal depression or let's
just talk about how we feel okay
and so I don't know if I had clinical
sad probably not but for the purpose of
the show I just want to continue to
challenge us beyond the diagnosis okay
depression feeling low
into full-blown I can't get out of bed
because I can't breathe right genetics
environment we said all that
um
here's a couple of things I've done over
the past few years and recently that
have made a tremendous difference now I
love the winter here it's Unique and
it's different but I love it
um I did buy and I spent some money on
it okay so this is not cheap I got the
expensive version of probably not the
expensive version but I did not go for
the cheapest option
um but I recently bought
um it's a box lamp from I wrote it down
here northern light technology this is a
box light it's about 180 bucks it's
expensive
there's a bunch of them that you can buy
for 25 30 35 bucks that are basically
art lamps right that you draw use them
to draw with or to trace with
um mine has I think 10 000 Lux you can
get them as low as 900 or a thousand
I just turn it on in the morning and I
put it 12 to 14 inches for my face and I
just have my coffee and I do my morning
gratitude journal and stuff in the
morning
um and I just have it on occasionally
I'll glance at it but it has made a
tremendous difference in what I call
like the domino effect and these
dominoes go one way and they can also go
the other way okay
um Dr huberman has done a great job over
the past couple of years pointing out
how critical
light is especially in the morning
um to our eyes into our brain function
and then our overall Downstream
physiology so for years it was important
for me just to get outside in the
morning I didn't realize what a benefit
that was simply because of the sunlight
I thought it was because of the cold
exposure which I'm sure had something to
do that I thought it was because of the
grounding I like to go outside with any
shoes on
but turns out it probably the most
important thing I was doing was getting
sunlight even on cloudy days even on
overcast days
um and when you wake up and it is just
pitch black and I get up super early
having this lamp has been a game changer
for me
um also going outside is a big deal so
here's a couple of so so number one make
it a point to get Bright Lights even if
you just wake up in the morning and turn
the lights on by the way if you wake up
and continue to lay prone late lay down
and just scroll your phone the worst
thing you can do at least open your eyes
and sit up
sit up and turn the lights on and if
you're married and somebody's just
crashed out and if you turn the lights
on they're gonna stab you with the
nearest sharp object then leave the room
and go somewhere where you can sit
straight up and you can turn the lights
on I even do my meditations after I have
some time in front of this light just to
get me what just to wake me up and I go
back and turn the lights off in in the
basement
um get light in your eyes get light in
your eyes get light in your eyes morning
walk great bundle up and go for a walk
have a lot whatever it looks like okay
here's
um a common thing that happens and it's
just it's The Dominoes going the other
way
right so you start your morning with
light you start your morning with your
gratitude you start morning with your
exercise your caffeine you're starting a
set of dominoes one way and that one way
is going to be an optimized mind a body
that's up an atom a positive a more
positive attitude a more positive
morning routine
it also goes the other way
so if you wake up in the morning and you
hit snooze and you hit snooze and that
cold and that cold room you feel so good
because you're under warm covers in that
cold room and you just stay in the dark
and stay in the dark and you're in that
there's some technical words for it but
you're in that that I call it that
underwater space when you're not fully
asleep but you didn't go back to I mean
you can go back to sleep all the way but
you're not really awake
you're just kind of there and also you
wait until the last possible you pop up
out of your bed and you sprint into the
shower and you take a thousand degree
shower super hot you brush your teeth
and you grab a bar of some sort you run
out the door to go to work
you have just started the dominoes with
your cortisol with your adrenal with
your whole fight-or-flight system
and you head down you start those
dominoes and then bam by nine o'clock
ten o'clock unless you're got an iron
will you're grabbing
something from the candy Bowl in the
office or somebody shows up with donuts
and you're like I'll have six and then
you're grabbing more coffee and more
coffee and more coffee and then a Red
Bull and then somebody's like hey dude
you like Monster drinks and you're like
no I like my trucks like a regular
person without being 17 inches off the
ground but I'll have a monster like you
start that you go on that road
and a common side effect of seasonal
affective disorder and I happen to be of
the opinion that one begets the other
is as the days get shorter
substance abuse increases your drugs of
choice and so people will drink a little
bit more they will grab another drink
and another drink or they'll have us
start smoking again they'll it's just it
just feels like it's right because Cole
let's grab a cigarette whatever it is
go to holidays and then you drink and
then it messes up your sleep and now
you're back in the morning and you don't
want to get out of bed and see what I'm
saying like The Dominoes have gone that
way I call it the the the underwater
effect you just slowly find yourself
under water and then man mid to late
December you're in the holidays and it's
family drama and stuff and you're over
budget
and you just can't get out of bed
right you've just locked it down so
um and by the way you're not exercising
at that point you're just eating
whatever you can get it so it just
starts a cycle so I want to be
intentional on the front end of this
cycle
um here's some things I have found
besides the light okay that keep me from
going down that cycle it's to go the
other direction
um and they are these are not going to
be popular and what I'll tell you is you
get to choose your heart do you want to
have hard miserable short days that are
cold and dark and just
or do you want to have hard days that
you do hard things and it's you are
enjoying these days you get to pick one
both of them are going to be hard okay
and I've done them both and I am
choosing
the optimistic joyful
um hard things to do okay number one I
don't drink during the holidays
I just don't
if I if you do
watch how you feel and make sure you
don't skip your routine the next morning
regardless of how much you have to drink
the night before
I just adds to it compresses an already
devolving mood and I've just not found
it to be worth it and then it starts
messing up my sleep and it makes it hard
to get up in the morning and then I eat
junk food it just starts a whole set of
dominoes I know holiday parties and I
know holiday family time some of you the
only way to get through holiday time is
with one or two or seven or nine glasses
of wine
be really intentional about cutting back
your alcohol intake if you can't this is
a great time of year to say I'm going to
start a new and get on top of that
um cold water exposure I won't go into
all the nerd stuff about it
whether you're going outside and I went
to Tractor Supply and got a 100 tub and
it's I filled up with water I haven't
done it in a while but I used to do it
every single day
um
it's transformative two or three minutes
and you think you're gonna die
um my son used to get into in there with
me for a couple for for several months
um now I rarely rarely
um take anything other than a cold
shower in the morning and I get my water
comes from a well and from a spring like
out of the out of the side of a mountain
uh outside the hill and it's cold and
it's it's transformative again in the
morning
um militant about exercising I just
don't miss especially between November
and January unless I'm sick I don't miss
I go do something down there I go to and
then I say down there in my home gym
just have a couple of Weights in my
basement
um don't miss you gotta move your body
some of you don't have any weights
you're not interested in that great go
for a walk if you can't go for a run go
for a walk if you can go for a walk just
go outside and I don't know just walk
around your front yard You Gotta Move
Your Body okay
um and then I count calories this is a
whole Downstream set of drama
um not in a Draconian way or not like in
a uh like I've got a headband on and my
wife's got leg warmers and we're like
doing Jane Fonda and we're like have a
like a menthol cigarette and a tab and
we're like we're gonna count calories
not like that
but I'm intentional about what I'm
eating and how much because it's just so
easy to grab a cookie and then another
cookie and then another cookie and then
let's go ahead and grab this and I'm
gonna put
extra cream in here I'm gonna get some
more bacon and suddenly I'm I'm adding a
thousand calories per day and that just
has an effect on how I feel and how I
move in My overall mood and and and
um there is some
yeah this is gonna give or take I take
vitamin D K2 I get it from Thorn and
remember uh go thorn.com you slash
deloni and you can get 25 off everything
um I do take it I I think the efficacy
is we're still trying to figure that out
but um
meaning I don't know if supplementing
with vitamin D is as important as going
outside and getting Vitamin D naturally
but I'd do it anyway
um and then I'm outside a lot I'm a big
hunter and big Walker um I like to be
outside a lot and so even when it's
freezing freezing freezing cold but
there's just outdoor exposure and sun
and changing temperatures all these
things lift mood
okay
here's an important thing before I wrap
it up depression is very very real and
it's very very dangerous okay holidays
can be a heavy time too
if you find yourself underwater and the
idea of these things I just said like I
can't take a cold shower
I can't get out of bed
I'm starting to have hard conversations
with myself about whether I need to be
here anymore
whether I'm ever going to get these
debts paid off I'm never gonna be able
to stop drinking or stop eating
and you have Suicidal Thoughts thoughts
about quitting life or you find yourself
looking at pornography again and again
and again and grabbing another drink and
another drink
call somebody
the world would not be better without
you here and it's very flippant of me to
say oh it's all just a bunch of behavior
it is you can change a lot of it but
some of you are going to be in
a statistical minority of folks who are
suffering from deep depression and you
gotta Reach Out gotta reach out and if
you love somebody who's struggling don't
just say oh you need to exercise I'm
gonna turn all the lights on in the
morning not cool
model by example lead with love okay
if you find yourself you can't do
anything
make that call